so I'm going to focus on malaria and as
we've heard already today uh malaria is
it's a it's a complex disease in some
ways because it's driven by a suite of
factors some of them intrinsic so
aspects of the ecology and the biology
and the environment rainfall humidity
habitat which species we've got but it's
also then strongly influenced by a suite
of extrinsic fact S A lot of those
linked through to socioeconomic factors
access to bed nets types of housing air
conditioning drugs Etc and and it's
possible for these extrinsic factors to
really um outweigh the intrinsic factors
so that's as we heard earlier this
morning why we don't have malaria in
Florida for instance perfect environment
some competent vectors but still the
extrinsic factors have sort of
overridden that that that basic biology
so going forward the balance of how much
malaria is going to change through the
influences of climate is still going to
be strongly influenced by the the
presence or absence of these extrinsic
factors but I'm going to talk about
these intrinsic factors and how much
temperature in particular is going to
impact on uh transmission potential okay
so my focus is not so much about
rainfall or humidity but I'm going to
focus on temperature is one of the key
environmental drivers of malaria
transmission so just to oh they're all
labed one I Can Do I Can Count better
than
that um so um my first point will be I
just want to highlight why I think we
should focus on temperature why
temperature is important uh then want to
move on to some discussion about
temporal resolution what do we actually
mean by temperature then touch on some
very recent work which is still work in
progress about um actually how do we
take broadscale temperature predictions
and come down to come up with something
that's more focused dealing with this
issue of spal resolution and finally I
just want to touch very briefly at the
end um on some knowledge gaps some
things some key areas I think that are
important that we deal with if we're
going to do a better job of projecting
into the
future so why is temperature
important we already had a very nice
primer on this this morning um that um
transmission potential can be
characterized by this term this this
metric vectorial capacity gives us a
measure of the transmission potential of
a mosquito popul
and there are a bunch of important bits
of biology that go into determining that
so we've got and and and it's quite
intuitive actually
so um M uh ratio of mosquitoes to humans
so obviously if you're in an environment
there are very few mosquitoes in an
environment with many more mosquitoes
you'd expect more transmission with more
mosquitoes a is a measure of biting rate
so more bites if mosquitoes are biting
once every two days or once in every
seven days then obviously more bites
more potential for
transmission how long the mosquitoes
live whether they're dying off very
quickly or whether they're living for a
long time again longer living more trans
transmission potential and that's
particularly important in relation to
this other term which we heard about
already again uh the extrinsic
incubation period which describes the
length of time it takes for the parasite
or virus to develop inside the mosquito
so from an initial infectious meal
parasite migrates to the gut develops in
the gut developmental stages replication
in Oasis these Oasis then rupture
releasing the SP rites which migrate to
the salivary glands invade the salivary
glands and at that point that mosquito
can transmit malaria the whole duration
of that period is the extrinsic
incubation period and then there are a
couple other terms that that enter into
vectorial capacity which basically
Define transmission efficiencies and a
lot of this is tied up and links back to
whether the mosquito is a competent
vector and that itself further links to
aspects of mosquito immunity whether
it's able to kill off or Harbor the
parasite successfully and the point
about all of these is we're dealing with
with mosquito small coldblooded insects
all aspects of these ecology and
physiology of mosquitoes are strongly
driven by temperature okay that's why
temperature matters and you can see an
example of that this is a recent
synthesis paper an ecology
letters where basically most of those
parameters there were draw through the
literature and come up with the sort of
best guess estimates of what the
temperature dependen is of these
parameters and you can see without doubt
that they're all strongly temperature
dependent they're strongly nonlinear
they don't all share the same
relationships you've got important uh
nonlinearities such that very small
changes in temperature can have very big
impacts on rate at certain points of the
curve there are other parts of the curve
where the relationship's rather flat
doesn't matter if you go one or two
degrees either way there and there are
also then areas where it gets very bad
okay so as you change through
temperature you might expect some of
these rate prices to go up some of them
not to change and some of them to go
down and importantly they don't all
share the same relation relationship so
one thing has the potential to be going
up at the same time as something else is
going down okay so understanding these
relationships is really important
because these are the things that go
into vectorial capacity vectorial
capacity is what determines transmission
intensity and they're all driven by
temperature another way sort of another
another illustration of that is sort of
slightly more pictorial illustration
this is an this is a map of Kenya taken
from the malaria Atlas project providing
a which gives us a measure of um annual
plasmodium falcifer and parasite rate so
a measure of parasite burden or
transmission across Kenya and I just
draw your attention so it's a it's a
heat map so areas in red have high
transmission and these areas in Gray
here malaria are malaria free and the
reason I put this up is because what you
can see here is that you can go from an
area of intense transmission to zero
transmission across very small spatial
scale basically you go about 50 km and
you go from lots and lots of malaria to
no malaria and that's not a great
gradient of bed nets it's not a gradient
of drugs insecticide resistance it's not
a gradient of housing wealth poverty
it's just a gradient of temperature
these are the low sites next to Lake
Victoria high transmission area and
these are the canyon Highlands so going
up altitude going up in temperature
going down in temperature rather means
that essentially you go from lots of
transmission To
None simply by the influence of these
intrinsic factors okay so what we want
to do is to be able to understand how
temperature is contributing to these
different patterns of
transmission
so I'm talking about temperature so
which bits of temperature are we talking
about what's important to understand
here
um we tend to characterize talk about
transmission environments as we all say
it's a 20° environment or it's
25° we tend to talk about mean monthly
temperatures sometimes daily
temperatures sometimes even longer than
that season long temperatures and
certainly when it comes to looking at
climate projections a lot of what we're
talking about is shifts in mean
temperature a rise of 2 de in mean
annual temperature or mean monthly
temperature or some
such but if you look at temperature and
temperature that actually mosquitoes
experience in the real world well you
get a very different picture so these
are some temperature data taken from a
village Hut in ifakara in a high
transmission setting in Tanzania so
these are actually indoor temperature
data so if the mosquito was resting
indoors this is what it would be
experiencing and you can see in this
environment that the the overall mean is
just a little bit over
25° but along any one day then it's not
actually experiencing 25 degrees so
there are parts of the Season where it's
a 20° environment Parts where it's more
of a 30° environment but also more what
also turns out to be important is that
throughout the day you get considerable
variation in temperature between the
daily minimum and the daily maximum so
the mosquito sat in this environment is
going from here maybe down to 20° up to
35 de even though the mean is
26 so we're experiencing this
considerable temperature variation
varying from hour to hour as temperature
fluctuates throughout the day and
mosquitoes small cold blooded their body
temperatures are going to track very
closely these shifts in ambient
temperature okay so mosquito doesn't
experience the mean temperatures it
experience what it experiences this full
Suite of fluctuation and the same is
true for the Laval habitat so so adults
living in in terrestrial environment but
we've got lvi in these aquatic habitats
these are temperature data taken from
some different pools in uh two Highland
sites in Kenya and the point of putting
this up is simply to show that in the
different Siz pools we've got
considerable fluctuation in the water
body in the temperature temperatures of
these water bodies throughout the day
and also that these water temperatures
this is what the lvi are experiencing
are actually different to the ambient
temperatures so if you to take ambient
temperature to dry and drive your model
then actually you wouldn't be
characterizing what the L are
experiencing okay they are experienced
they're tracking
very considerable fluctuation throughout
the day okay so the question then is
does this daily temperature variation
matter is it okay to Simply say well
it's a 25 degree environment or an 18
degree environment whatever it is or do
we need to actually capture the
influence of this daily temperature
variation of course I wouldn't be
laboring this point if the answer wasn't
yes uh so we've been looking at that
question for uh the last few years now
um a suite of sort of um um
uh some sort of theoretical studies but
also a range of some empirical studies
so I'll just give an example of two of
those studies so the are our our
approach to sort of addressing this
question is to do experiments in in
incubators like this where we're able to
program the incubators to actually
either have the a mean temperature a
constant mean temperature and that's the
way that most people would do the work
you'd set your incubator and that's the
way if you go to a mosquito insectary
somebody working on malaria nearly every
insectary in the world is set at 20 6 or
27 degrees and doesn't vary at all so
that's what you do set your constant
incubator um but what we do is to have
uh constant temperatures but also then
compare that with realistic Doo
fluctuations okay the same mean
temperatures but actually putting in
some realistic Doo temperature range and
what that allows us to do is to for
instance compare low and high mean
temperatures what's happening how are
the low and high mean temperatures
impacting on aspects of mosquito and
parasite biology but then also what
happen happens if we superimpose on top
of that some realistic measure of D
temperature variation so comparing for
instance uh 16 and then 16 plus or minus
6 so a dial temperature range of 12 um
and in the previous example we saw that
we can get dtrs of 12 perfectly
reasonably or 26 again with a plus or
minus 6 what's the difference does that
variation matter and is it the same at
the cold end as well as the warm
end so these are some data where we're
looking at parasite development right so
and this is a slightly complicated
figure so I'll take a little bit of time
to walk through it what we're measuring
here is the impact of temperature on
parasite development the growth kinetics
of the malaria parasite inside the
mosquito we've got cool temperature over
here 16 warm temperature over here and
then these panels themselves are broken
into two parts so let's just concentrate
in the first instance on the left hand
side what we're looking at here are the
growth kinetics the replication rate of
the malaria parasites inside the Oasys
in the mosquito gut so the the mosquito
has these o the parasites replicating
away and at a certain point it's going
to burst and liberate those parasites so
what we're able to do is to actually
count those number of parasites to get a
measure of the growth kinetics okay so
it's 16° and we've got temperatures
we've got treatments which are
fluctuating that's the dotted line with
the wiggly symbol or the solid line is
the constant temperature treatment what
you can see then is that fluctuation
acts to speed up parasite development so
16° parasite growth rate is much faster
in the presence of variation
versus constant mean temperature so you
get completely different growth kinetics
things speeding up with fluctuation
around the cold end interestingly you
get the reverse pattern if you impose
fluctuation at the warm end okay so here
the constant temperature treatment at 26
the parasites growing very well here it
starts to slow down through the
influence of this variation so we've got
realistic temperature variation that's
what the mosquito would be experiencing
in the real world and that gives you
different growth kinetics of the
parasite different parasite development
rate
depending on whether you have variation
or not so if you were to say it's a 16°
environment that wouldn't tell you what
parasite development is you need to know
whether it's 16 plus or minus whatever
okay it's a little bit even more extreme
of that this measure over here is
dissemination which is actually a
measure of the proportion of mosquitoes
which had sporo in their in their in the
Hemo limpin migrating into the salivary
glands and essentially um in this
treatment and this is I should point out
this is done with plasmodium shodi it's
a rodent malaria
area doesn't really matter that that
actually except that the absolute
temperatures are different so it
temperature Optima temperature thermal
performance curve is slightly different
from plasmodium falum but nonetheless
they share the same qualitative
shape um we actually find that the
proportion of mosquito so none of the
mosquitoes in the constant 16 degree
treatment actually became infectious so
the limit to malaria transmission you
can't say just from the mean
temperatures because it's it was
actually rescued by having some
temperature variation so not only did
the parasite veloped faster but also
mosquitoes went on went on to become
infectious because of the influence of
temperature variation and you get the
reverse pattern over here none of the
mosquitoes in the constant 26 treatment
actually in the variable 26 treatment
actually uh were able to transmit
malaria
okay um so that's the parasite trait
really important one that influences um
What proportion of mosquitoes become
infectious and how long it takes this
extrinsic incubation period is
determined by mean temperature but also
by the pattern of
variation we can take that through to
Mosquito traits themselves this is
looking at again an off Stevens side
looking at lval development so we ran an
experiment looking at a whole range of
temperatures looking at development rate
and survival through to um pupation or
through to adulthood of the mosquito
lvi so we do this range of constant
temperature experiments generating these
thermal performance curves that's the
standard approach you do it at 20° 22 24
26 get the nice curves here slightly
asymmetric curve here more
characteristic symmetric curve here for
survival and then we take a three three
of those temperatures one from the co
end one from the warm end and um around
the optimum rather and one from the warm
end and then we add in the influence of
temperature variation so this is what we
expect to happen and now we've added in
variation and what you can see again
consistent with the previous finding is
that temperature variation as we start
to add in small or larger variation acts
to slow rate processes down so we get
slower developmental rate here and
actually a much bigger impact on
Survival so dramatically reduced
survival through the presence of
variation at the warm end and increase
development and improve survival through
variation at the cold end so if we're to
try to characterize the environment
we're talking about a change in
temperatures from 20° to 25 degrees for
instance that won't necessarily tell us
what impact that's going to have on uh
development rate or survival unless we
understand also what the influence of
the daily temperature variation is and
again this interesting contrasting
effects of variation at the warm end
slowing things down variation at the
cold end acting to speed things up and a
lot of work is done on characterizing
these types of thermal performance
curves many many studies lots of studies
doing constant temperature work and you
end up with measures here for instance
which would give you a measure of the CT
Max the critical maximum temperature at
which you might get survivorship or
development and these are used in a lot
of different studies to to explore the
effects for instance of climate change
well it's I think it's a really I think
it's a really interesting and important
insight it that actually the CT Max
can't be determined based simply on the
mean temperatures you run you would say
here that the CT Max is around 35° but
actually if you put a bit of variation
in CT Max is lower somewhere down at 32°
and variation exists in the real world
we don't exist in a constant temperature
environment
okay so some important points from that
um uh daily temperature variation
affects the sort of essential um host
and parasite relationships that combine
to determine transmission
intensity uh so I've just shown two but
we've looked at this for this whole
Suite of mosquito and parasite
traits we find that the the the effects
are slightly complex because variation
around the cool end seems to speed
things up relatively variation around
the warm end tends to slow things down
relative to the mean temperatures and on
average that tends to alter the shape of
these thermal performance curves these
reaction norms and actually acts to make
them slightly flatter so if one is in a
variable environment and you actually
track across the shape of that curve it
tends to reduce the overall impact of
climate change relatively okay I think
an important point is that neither the
upper in this case for Malia but it
extends I think to other species as well
neither the upper or lower bounds of
malaria transmission can be determined
from mean temperature alone it's mean
plus whatever the variation is and
that's really important when we're
talking about the effects of climate
changes at the edge of range when we go
into the canyan Highlands and we're
talking about an 18° environment where
the malaria parasites just hanging on in
there well it's going to matter not just
whe what the Shi in mean temperature is
but also what the daily temperature
range is and how that's going to change
into the future as well and I think
importantly none of the long-established
empirical relationships or numerous
modeling Studies have taken into account
these effects okay so I think we're
missing an important part of the biology
of how small etms are responding to this
variation in the
environment
um and just to sort of um illustrate
what that might mean then uh I just give
a a quick example of some recent work uh
where we've been exploring so now we
know that temperature variation matters
and temperature variation impacts for
instance or is going to impact uh the
extrinsic incubation period so what we
do in this next study is to ask the
question well what would what would the
extrinsic incubation PE be extrinsic
incubation period be if we just use mean
temperatures versus what the predictions
would be if we allowed for dial
temperature range and we allowed the
parasite to track temperature as it
fluctuates throughout the day
okay and we put that into a um bunch of
models which I'm not going to go into
basically generating temperature
surfaces using those temperature
surfaces to generate parasite
development models or parasite growth
models uh we use a um long-term
uh about 10 years worth of environmental
data to generate the surfaces and and
all I've done here is to pick out an
illustrative month for each quarter okay
and this is the prediction this is so
this is obviously Africa this is the
limits of malaria transmission um so
this is pretty much where the malaria
occurs and this is the prediction of
extrinsic incubation period for these
months um based if we use the
conventional model and use just mean
monthly temperatures and you can see
that we get considerable temporal and
spatial variation areas red colors where
the parasit is developing very quickly
some of the lighter cooler colors where
it's taking a long time to develop and
there are these white areas where in
fact the parasite takes so long to
develop that we that you can't get
transmission because the mosquitoes are
dead Okay mosquitoes don't live that
long what's interesting is that you get
a very different pattern um if you
actually drive the model and allow the
the effect of hourly temperatures
temperature variation to Drive parasite
development rather than simply talking
about the meain temperatures
Okay so we've got now different patterns
variation over time and space and and
you get the best sort of picture of the
difference between those two when you
take one away from the other so what
we've got here is the percentage
difference in parasite development time
parasite growth rate depend between
these two
predictions um essentially where the
blue colors here are are indicating that
parasite development is I was get this
the wrong way around I should look at my
figure myself um parasite development is
taking uh longer through the influence
of temperature variation and the red
colors are indicating where parasite
development is actually quicker through
the influence of variation compared with
the means Okay so we've got considerable
variation um in parasite development
rate errors that we would if we if we
were to take the main temperatures and
predict parasite development rate would
say that but they'd be wrong by plus or
minus 100% depending on whether you're
in a cool end or a warm end and when you
add in the influence of variation okay
so as a prediction of parasite
development rate and if one was to build
on that and extend that through to have
a map of mar malaria transmission then
variation has a big impact compared with
just talking about mean
temperatures so
um so what we've seen there is that
temperature variation is important uh we
need to think about what it is that the
mosquito is experiencing in nature and
not just necessarily talk about average
conditions um we've heard today quite a
lot about not only the need to Now sort
of think about the spatial resolution
that we need to talk about or consider
in in understanding temperature but also
then the need to actually come up with
local scale predictions of what or
projections of what's going to happen to
malaria transmission into the future at
the moment we have gcms providing
broadscale predictions
Regional uh Regional level large scale
predictions as to what's going to happen
and changes in average conditions but
what we'd like to know what we'd like to
be able to do is a fin a resolution
prediction and actually come down to
have some sort of downscale predictions
of saying what's going to happen in this
site versus this site and that's
particularly important when you think
about somewhere like Kenya if you cast
your mind back to that first map I
showed where you've got dramatic changes
in transmission intensity over very
small spatial scales we don't want a Big
Grid cell that covers that whole area
and says it's going to be like this
because we already know that across just
20 20 miles it's high here and low here
so we need to be able to downscale those
Productions to be able to come up with
that spal resolution to better
understand local
transmission so what I want to talk
about now is some very recent work where
we've been trying to take that approach
of doing some climate downscaling to
drive a malaria transmission model to
allow us to better understand what might
happen into the future at these local
scales and I'm going to pick uh we've
picked Kenya again and we're going to
focus on these four sites kitali kumu
kichu and
gissa um we pick these they're largely
uh more or less equivalent latitudes but
they vary considerably in their
background temperatures and I'll show
you that in a moment particularly the
difference between Kumo which is a high
transmission site and kucho and katali
because these are both higher altitude
SES so they have very low transmission
and then gissa over here also has rather
low transmission but for a different
reason and that's because it's actually
too hot so it's gone beyond the
temperature Optimum Okay so we've got
differences here we've got Optimum
temperatures cold temperatures and warm
temperatures and you can see that here
so we've got um these are these four
sides this is just for illustration this
is the parasite development rate curve
uh with temperature and we've got the
main temperatures for each of these
sites picked out with these yellow dots
here so you can see in kichu kicho and
katali high altitude sites cool mean
temperatures and superimposed on that
we've got these red arrows which
indicate the average extent of daily
temperature range so again in these
environments we've got considerable
variation 18 degrees but going up to 25
down to 10 and in gissa for instance a
really warm environment but for parts of
the day um actually getting into really
hot temperatures Okay so we've got
different we've got different meain
temperatures different variations at
different points on those parasite
development curves
so what we're going to do what we've
been doing in this work is is uh
downscaling um a a suite of global
climate models to provide environmental
temperature data at temporal and spatial
resolutions uh that are appropriate for
the parasite interaction that reflect
the local ecology and through that what
we hope to be able to do is generate
these sight specific predictions of the
impact of climate change what's climate
change going to do for transmission
potential in kicho versus kumu the
moment with broadscale gcms we couldn't
answer that
question and we've been doing this and
when I say we I mean these guys so
Robert Crane and and the devil incarnate
Mike man
um then uh so uh we've been I've been
working with these guys to who've been
uh developed an empirical downscaling
procedure now I don't understand a lot
about this there are going to people in
this room that understand a lot more
about it than I do but the procedure
takes uh nsep reanalysis data to train a
suite of gcms using a self-organizing
map which is an artificial neuron
Network kind of clustering algorithm to
train those down to um site specific to
provide more sight specific estimates of
temperature so putting that another way
it fits these core scale GCM projections
to a higher resolution by training them
down to empirical observations okay and
that's the extent of my knowledge of the
downscaling approach
approach but what we get is something
like this so the this is an illustration
for
kumu
um we're comparing uh sort of
contemporary or recent historical data
1983 to 2000 with future projections
based on the um uh standard sort of
emissions as usual model
um we've got a suite of gcms so there
are actually eight gcms uh that were
that were most amable for uh utilizing
in the downscaling approach and we've
got um mean temperatures and um doal
temperature range from these predictions
for each of these sites and as I said
this is just at the
moment so we've got um The Suite of uh
this Suite of gcms providing estimates
site specific estimates or as best as
you can get as a site specific estimate
um for kisumu and you can see that
there's considerable variation amongst
the individual
gcns uh now the standard way of dealing
with that would be to well so so we've
seen earlier that there's this sort of
Ensemble effect and so you have high and
low GCM predictions and so when we take
the ensemble mean but even if you take
the ensemble mean from the gcms that
doesn't actually do a very good job of
matching of overlaying with the actual
temperature data so the black line here
is the Met station temperature data the
actual observation data from for this
site for that period so even if you were
to take the ensemble mean doesn't
actually do a very good job and this may
not be surprising to anybody in the
audience but it was it was really
interesting to me that if you were to
take anyone GCM whether you really
wouldn't necessarily be doing a very
good job of characterizing what's
happening in a particular site and even
the ensemble mean doesn't do a very good
job either with the downscaling approach
essentially what we do is to draw those
gcms onto a focal point and actually do
a much better job of getting rid of lot
of that variation and it also now
overlaps and does a pretty good job of
characterizing the actual temperature at
that site and the same is true not only
for main temperatures but also for the
doo temperature range again considerable
variation in the the the sort of
predictions or expectations of doal
temperature range from the individual
gcms uh but they can be um trained
downscaled to come up with a much better
prediction overlapping with the actual
observational data so we've got some
confidence that given that the Downs
scared models do a good job and we can
validate against these uh observational
data that we can then take them forward
and actually use those downscaling
projections to come up with more refined
estimates of changes in climate into the
future both of means and of dtrs okay so
again lots and lots of variation here um
much more um fine-tune predictions much
more agreement between the individual
gcms through the downscaling
approach so we've done that for each
site and this is a way of sort of
summarizing that
um these are looking at the mean
temperatures now mean temperatures into
the future and this is DTR and D
temperature range and Di temperature
range into the future this is the one:
one line and the blue dots are for the
downscaled models and the black dots are
The Ensemble means from the raw
gcms so you can see that with the raw
gcms there's considerable variation so
that's the ensemble mean and that's the
sort of highest individual GCM and the
lowest individual GCM and similarly here
so lots of variation between the gcms
but it what but um interestingly even
the uh even The Ensemble means don't
actually do a very good job of matching
up with The downscaled Ensemble means
okay so and they do so in different ways
so for instance here gissa the warm
environment the downscaled model uh the
the raw gcms The Ensemble means actually
underestimate temperature and in these
cooler environments the GCM means
compared with the down scale models are
overestimating the mean Baseline
temperature now into the future so this
is the one to one line so each of these
pretty much shows a two degree warming
okay so that's what we expect a shift in
mean temperature they all agree that
it's a 2 degree warming but the Baseline
temperature from which they're starting
is different based on the gcms versus
the downscaled models and with the
dtrs lots of variation amongst the gcms
rather less again against the through
the downscaled models they all
consistently show a small reduction in
dinal temperature range due to partly a
a slight increase a greater increase in
nighttime temperatures relative to
daytime temperatures so we get a shift
in warming but a slight reduction in
nighttime temperatures and we need to
characterize both those things because
both means and temperature variation
matter for parasite transmission and our
measure of trans transmission that we've
been using is individual vectorial
capacity now this is a subset of the
sort of more typical vectoral capacity
model vectorial capacity provides a
measure of transmission intensity for a
mosquito population so that actually
requires that we have a measure of M the
numbers of mosquitoes per host now M
this can be influenced by many things
other than temperature it can be
influenced certainly by the availability
of ID position sites suitable lavel
breeding habitats and also strongly
influenced by control interventions and
it's rather difficult and if you look at
the the models do a rather poor job of
actually looking at how temperature
influences mosquito abundance so we've
actually taken that out of the equation
so what individual vectoral capacity
gives us is the expected number of a
measure of number of infectious bites
from a single Vector um having fed on an
infectious host so we've got now an
infected mosquito we want to know if in
this environment we've got an infected
mosquito what's going to happen to its
ability to transmit disease is it going
to go up or is it going to go down okay
so it's not an absolute measure of
transmission
intensity
and what we've got then is that we can
look at this individual vectoral
capacity both current and into the
future based on those temperatures based
on the the um meain temperatures and the
D temperature range using the downscaled
models the blue dots versus the uh raw
gcms for these four different sites cool
sites an intermediate site and a hot
site again you get a number of
interesting patterns here um first of
all that the the current estimates of
transmission intensity are different
because between the gcms and the down
Scout models because the the mean
temperatures that came out of those
models were different but also the rate
of change or the extent of change is
different into the future okay and so
down here and I'll show you this in a
little bit in a table over here that's
going to appear down here we've got
these cold sites uh rather low initial
transmission intensity these gradients
these Contours show whether it's getting
holder so essentially where the
transmission's going down or whether
it's going up relative to this one: one
line each one of these is a 25% increase
or decrease the Contours here so
actually down here even though
transmission intensity is very low we do
in fact get a really really large
increase in expected transmission
intensity due to climate warming okay
and I'll show this in a minute but it's
actually even though the Baseline is
lower it's a much bigger change
predicted through the downscale models
than you actually get from the raw GCM
for kumu this intermediate site um again
it's not in exactly the same place but
one gets roughly equivalent increases in
transmission intensity what's
interesting is for gissa with the gcms
all of the gcms predict that we're going
to have an increase in transmission
intensity but actually for uh gissa with
the Downs scale models we actually get
this two-tail prediction we've actually
gone over the temperature Optimum and an
increase further in temperature will
actually reduce transmission intensity
so we've got complex pattern of complex
effects of temperature at very local
scales by taking gcms downscaling them
driving them using those to drive
appropriate models sensitive to
temperature variation and we get from
that that sometimes malaria is going to
increase sometimes it's going to more
remain more or less the same sometimes
it's going to go down and you can see
that so these are the differences in
relative
Transmission in Into the Future based on
either the GCM or the downscaled models
and you can see that for the cool higher
altitude sites kicho and katali the GCM
say well there should be about an 100%
increase in transmission risk or
transmission intensity due to warming we
get a much higher increase in relative
transmission risk when we actually take
the GC the downscaled models to provide
a sight specific prediction so very
different outcomes 650 increase in
transmission intensity in in kicho by
taking the downscale models and actually
looking at the conditions in kicho and
not a broadscale
GCM for kumu it's uh slightly reduced or
about the same and importantly for gissa
it actually shows we predict a net
reduction in transmission intensity
whereas the gcms would predict an
increase okay so Divergent patterns of
predictions depending on be deriving
from the fact that we've taken these
broadscale models we've tuned them into
local data and actually we're using then
high resolution data to drive the models
with capturing the effects not just of
means but also of this
variation
so um so I think those uh those are
important insights those are very
different predictions for the impact of
climate change on malaria transmission
across a local level than one would get
from the standard models using mean
temperatures and using Co gcms okay very
different Divergent two-tail predictions
increases and decreases which we
wouldn't capture from the GCM
but in order to be able to do even
better I just wanted to highlight very
quickly uh I think a couple of knowledge
gaps things that we really need to know
better the first is that um I've already
made an argument that we need to
characterize the transmission
environment we need to know what it is
that mosquitoes are
experiencing uh we're still using Even
in our studies here um met station data
to help Define mean temperatures and D
temperature range but mosquito and met
stations are often T at airports but
mosquitoes don't live next to met
stations at airports mosquitoes live in
places like this so we get um so we've
got and we understand very little there
are very very few environmental data
that actually tell us this is a
transmission site in chenai uh um well
in India this is a transmission site in
urban chenai this is in Benin this is in
Kenya we have no environmental data that
tells us what the mosquito is actually
experiencing in these environments okay
if it's indoors versus Outdoors it's
going to be experiencing different
environments if it's indoors it's going
to be different depending on whether
it's a thatch roof versus a tin roof if
it's outdoors it's going to differ
whether it's aily heavily vegetated area
versus sparely vegetated if we're
talking about aquatic habitats it's
going to make a big difference depending
on whether the Laval habitat is an
overhead concrete tank versus if it's a
a puddle in a tire track we don't
actually know we have not done a very
good job of characterizing the
environmental conditions that mosquitoes
live
and we've known mosquitoes transmit
malaria for over 100 years we've done a
very good job of char a very poor job I
think of characterizing the environment
and characterizing their biology so we
need better data to actually take our
broadscale models met station models and
actually say what's that going to mean
for these individual transmission
environments because transmission
happens at this level not at the level
of the grid
cell I'd also then like to emphasize
that you know we've been using these
models uh these sort of character istic
relationships to help take the
temperature data which is poorly
resolved to drive these models but these
models are also really poorly resolved
this is the state-of-the-art paper that
was produced last year that pulled
together all the information possible to
help Define the influence of temperature
on these essential life history traits
for mosquitoes and the malaria parasite
but they're really rubbish I mean we're
being recorded aren't we um I didn't
mean that what I meant
was they could be much better they um it
wasn't really okay so um they're taken
from a mish mashing studies and some of
these you know so Vector competence for
instance is a really important measure
how good is a mosquito parasite at
incubating and transmitting the malaria
how good is a mosquito at incubating and
fully transmitting the malaria parasite
most models don't even include an
estimate of vector competence they just
say well it's one or it's a half or a05
or something like that but it clearly
isn't it's strongly temperatur dependent
but we have a very very poor
understanding of it this is all of the
data from 100 Years of research that
allows us to pull this together and it's
a mix Mas it's a mish mash of species so
some of it's been done on n's gambi some
of it's been done on stevensi some of
it's been done with falum some of it's
been done with vix you know you couldn't
take these data and use it to
parameterize and explain Transmission in
any one site you couldn't take those
data and to say well that's now going to
enable me to explain malaria
Transmission in this place in Tanzania
versus this place in India versus this
place somewhere else okay really poor
data and I think we we know we really
need to do better we need to do better
parameterization of these relationships
coupling together local mosquitoes with
local parasites okay and we need to tie
in considering not just the crude
effects of mean temperatures but also to
put in the effects of these
environmental variation and it's
particularly important when you've got
these contrasting traits so this is
Parasite development rate and this is
Vector competence and this is turns out
to be true we've done this work in the
lab the but actually over this over this
temperature range parasite development
rate does indeed go up it goes quicker
Vector competence over that same
temperature range goes down so the net
effect on transmission I mean if you
ignore Vector competence you're going to
say parasite development rate gets
faster more transmission but actually it
could be completely offset by a
declining Vector competence so that at a
warmer temperature you don't get any m a
transmission at all but we really don't
know we have a very poor understanding
of these relationships and again it's
something we really need to do a better
job
of so
some take-home messages I think
temperature matters temperature is a
really important driver of intrinsic
driver of malaria transmission when
we're talking about temperature we need
to think about what the mosquito
experiences so that means temperature
variation and not just the means these
effects of temperature are complex we
get potentially complex temperature by
trait interactions not everything is
scaling together not everything is
responding in the same
direction and importantly I think we
then need to sort of take this shift
towards trying to understand how
environment influences is the vector
parasite interactions acknowledging that
we live in an ecologically variable
world we don't live under mean
conditions and we need to take that down
to the scales that they're appropriate
to the interaction we need to think
about what's happening at the local
scale okay thank
you